e
[Aplausos]
eu sempre fui o tipo de pessoa que
decidiu colocar o modo silencioso do meu
celular no momento que eu decidi dormir
alguma coisa diferente aconteceu naquele
Dezesseis de setembro de 2018
Eu apenas escolher os dentes fechei a
porta do guarda-roupa e botei o telefone
ali no cantinho da minha cabeceira
era por volta mais ou menos eu acho que
dê umas duas da manhã quando o telefone
Começou a tocar bem alto e eu assustado
acordei ele o telefone Atende com aquela
voz sonolento mas não querendo parecer
que tava dormindo sabe mas era
impossível era duas horas da manhã Pedro
Pita se você tiver bem de saúde o teu
transplante pode acontecer ainda hoje
vem a imediatamente para a cidade de G1
e naquele momento de filme passou pela
minha cabeça
toda a euforia de pensar em poder viver
com saúde com qualidade de vida e
sem aquela sombra de dormir e ficar com
aquela tormenta de quem sabe morrer numa
fila eterna de transplante isso me deu
muita alegria e muita euforia
eu então sem muita noção de tempo e
espaço peguei as três primeiras pecinhas
de roupa que estavam perto de mim fiz a
minha malinha e furto quarto da minha
mãe e é ali na hora eu abrir a porta e
com grito que estava aqui preso na minha
garganta eu acordei a minha mãe e meu
padrasto dizendo é hoje é hoje que vai
ser o meu transplante eu vou ser
transplantado hoje aí
e já acordaram assustados para gente
trocou algumas palavras e fomos direto
para a cidade de Blumenau
G1
e durante a viagem
muita euforia Dentro daquele carro muita
alegria duas horas de distância de
Florianópolis que a cidade onde eu moro
e quando a gente chegou lá no hospital
Santa Isabel em Blumenau eu me deparei
com mais quatro pacientes que estavam
ali e tinham sido chamados para o mesmo
transplante que eu havia sido chamado
eu não entendi muito bem mas
aquilo é na verdade um procedimento
padrão que o hospital faz para que não
haja possibilidade de um descarte dos
órgãos captados então ele chama os cinco
pacientes que estejam mais próximo que
tenham a mesma tipagem sanguínea para
que ali em bloco eles saibam possa saber
fazem testes e Posso saber quem é o
paciente que vai ter o maior grau de
compatibilidade com os órgãos
e
a gente ficou ali os cinco numa salinha
durante mais ou menos umas quatro horas
sentadas esperando sem poder comer nada
sem beber uma gota d'água porque
precisava estar em jejum para poder
fazer a cirurgia de nesse tempo que a
gente ficou ali a gente podia um
conhecer melhor o outro cada um contava
sua história aquele que conseguia né
porque tava todo mundo muito mal muito
mal mesmo
até que era mais ou menos umas 8 horas
da manhã quando a enfermeira abriu a
sala onde a gente tava e sem muito
suspense ela anunciou
e o paciente que vai fazer o transplante
hoje é a paciente Ivana
E aí
e há um misto de sensações e entrou em
mim uma certa frustração
meu fiquei bem de isolado
mas ao mesmo tempo eu também fiquei
feliz porque eu pude ver a Ivana
tava muito pior do que eu
Ah mas essa frustração só se deu porque
a minha certeza de ser transplantado era
tão grande que eu não tinha dado esse
passo na minha mente para uma resposta
negativa
e isso tudo
aconteceram durante 10 vezes sim eu fui
até Blumenau durante 10 vezes 10 vezes
eu recebi a ligação de madrugada 10
vezes eu fiquei eufórico tive que pegar
o carro com a minha mãe com meu padrasto
e até a cidade de Blumenau e somente na
minha décima tentativa é que eu fui o
escolhido para poder fazer o transplante
os órgãos era 99% compartilhe isso
comigo
Tá bom mas para eu ir além dessa
história Eu Preciso Dizer para vocês o
porquê que eu tava ali prestes a
realizar aquele transplante eu fui
diagnosticado com diabetes tipo 1 quando
eu tinha 11 anos de idade e o mau
controle e o mal Convívio com a doença
me fez e para minha vida adulta com
várias complicações que fizeram eu poder
experimentar Sensações e dores que
talvez eu nunca tinha sentido antes uma
experiência de quase-morte eu tive
através de um cômodo para emagrecer por
15 dias tive problema de visão Tive
problemas nos meus rins e acabou gerando
uma doença renal crônica e essa
realmente chegou com muita força eu
precisei então ficar Refém de uma
máquina de hemodiálise
aonde eu fazia três sessões semanais
a onde eu ficava ali com bracinho parado
durante quatro horas
toda a semana no hospital na minha
cidade
isso gerava uma dor física Claro mas
também uma dor mental porque
nesse vai e vem de hospital eu acabei
conhecendo vários outros colegas que
também tinha o mesmo problema de saúde
que eu e assim como eu estava muito mal
esses colegas muitos deles não
resistiram e infelizmente terminaram uma
sua jornada aqui na terra
e eu percebia que o meu corpo já tava
dando sinais em muito muita fraqueza eu
estava literalmente muito saco isso é
aquele transplante não saísse o quanto
antes eu ia ser o próximo a morrer
também
mas o meu momento chegou Foi no dia sete
de dezembro de 2018 que os órgãos do
doador foi 98 por cento compartilhe isso
comigo e eu pude então e a chance de
Renascer através de um transplante
é mas eu percebi que para eu poder tá
ali fazendo aquele transplante algo
muito maior aconteceu antes
que foi um ato de solidariedade
é um ato de solidariedade através de um
sim o sim mais importante da minha vida
que foi um sim da mãe e da família
daquele doador
mesmo ali no leite de morte do seu filho
aquela mãe um momento tão doloroso
resolver perenizar o legado de seu filho
aqui na terra doando os seus órgãos e
salvando até oito vidas isso uma delas
foi a minha e com ele eu pude receber um
pâncreas e um rim e a justamente por
esse ato de solidariedade que eu tô
podendo aqui hoje contando a minha
história para vocês
e no Brasil
Essa é a lista de transplante ela
ultrapassa o número de 40 mil pessoas
e esse número ele pode sim baixar e quem
sabe até acabar e é muito simples basta
você que tem o desejo de ser doador de
órgãos avisar a sua família que você é
um doador de órgãos Pois somente Eles é
que vão poder fazer e dar o simples eu
desejo quando você já não tiver mais por
aqui então é muito importante que a
gente fale a respeito de doação de
órgãos coloque essa pauta numa reunião
de família da conversa com os amigos
porque falar de transplante é falar de
vida
Tá bom mas sobre o meu transplante
tudo aconteceu na mais perfeita sintonia
foram 12 horas de cirurgia
aonde eu tinha uma recuperação muito
rápida e uma semana eu já tava liberado
para ter alta do hospital e eu fiquei
ali na cidade de Blumenau mesmo junto
com a minha mãe dona Ivonete o meu
padrasto e Seu Jorge que foram assim
maravilhosos sempre tiveram comigo desde
o início dando maior força a maior
assistência maior carinho e ficamos
então ali num apartamento alugado por
que isso é uma Norma do hospital todo
paciente transplantado tem que ficar
pelo menos 90 dias próximo ao hospital
para se caso aconteça alguma
intercorrência ou alguma emergência do
hospital possa dar o socorro o quanto
antes e passou muito rápido foram três
meses mas passou voando e então a gente
retornou para Florianópolis e com vários
sonhos vários projetos aquele desejo de
voltar para a nossa rotina do dia-a-dia
e isso era o meu desejo era o desejo da
minha mãe era desejo no meu padrasto
então voltamos eufóricos
mas vocês estão percebendo que a vida do
Pedro ela se assemelha um pouco a uma
montanha russa né e eu posso dizer que
na minha volta para Florianópolis havia
uma pedra no meio do caminho
Pois é no meio do caminho havia uma
pedra e eu tropecei e tá bem acabei
fraturando o meu tornozelo em diversas
partes e Mais Uma Vez Outra cirurgia
foram 13 parafusos três placas hinos e
eu naquela situação de dependência sem
mobilidade que não era o Pedro que se
encontrava ali E aí
e eu não me envia naquela situação
então tive que fazer muita a sessão de
fisioterapia
reabilitação e repouso mas a verdade é
que eu não reconhecia o pé estava ali
comigo
e foi quando em outubro de dois mil e
vinte eu recebi o diagnóstico de
osteomielite crônica é uma doença que
afeta o osso através de uma infecção e o
meu médico disse que se eu não alterasse
as peças
essa osteomielite poderia avançar e
tomar minha perna toda e não só mais o
meu tornozelo
é percebido isso através de um
atendimento com muita simpatia do meu
médico ortopedista eu entendi que a
melhor opção naquele momento para mim
seria escolher pela amputação
pois neste momento eu pesei as coisas
eu já tinha me libertado das agulhinhas
da insulina já tinha me libertado das
Agulhas da hemodiálise e não seria o meu
pé esquerdo que iria me parar
Ah e não parou
eu não parei
eu fiz a minha cirurgia de amputação
e no dia seguinte sair do hospital e
decide bolar uma campanha chamada um é
para o Pedro aonde eu arrecadei dinheiro
para poder pagar a cirurgia que já havia
sido feita para poder comprar uma
prótese que me desse qualidade de vida e
me deixasse Uma vida sem limitações H
toda a parte de fisioterapia de
reabilitação e foi o sucesso foram
apenas 20 dias e eu consegui então
arrecadar todo esse dinheiro que era
necessário para tudo isso eu fiquei
extremamente feliz e cheio de gás para
poder dar continuidade
e toda essa situação de amputação de
prótese e fez perceber também que eu
acabo sendo um cara privilegiado Porque
a partir do momento que eu tô sem a
minha prótese do país Olá eu sou o cara
que acorde todos os dias com o pé
direito e isso eu faço questão de
transbordar para todo o meu dia Ou seja
faça o meu dia ficar positivo tenha
otimismo no meu dia
o mais engraçado ou talvez o mais
interessante é que nós usamos cotados a
gente consegue sentir o membro que já
não estão mais ali eu mesmo consigo
sentir o meu pé mexer meu pé coçar já
sente câimbra tem pessoas que sentem
dores terríveis isso em nome sobrenome
chama síndrome do membro Fantasma o mais
engraçado que aconteceu foi quando eu
estava deitado na minha cama sem a
prótese e me deu aquela vontade louca de
ir no banheiro aquele chique não tem
como escapar e você então quer sair
desesperado e não foi diferente comigo
e
no impulso coloquei para fora a minha
perna o meu pai Qual o pé que eu coloco
primeiro
o pé amputado o pé fantasma você sabe
que aconteceu né claro caí no chão bati
com a cabeça mas enfim fiquei ali parado
e rindo da situação
bom o que eu quero contar aqui através
da minha história claro que apenas um
recorte porque eu Pedro Pita eu não sou
apenas a diabetes a o transplante ou
amputação isso claro faz parte da minha
vida mas não somente isso não é o todo o
Pedro é muito mais do que isso
claro que eu adoro ser um exemplo de
superação ser visto como inspiração ou
poder motivar outras pessoas isso é
maravilhoso mas a gente e também que o
bacana da vida é poder viver a vida
intensamente eu não digo o viver no modo
vida louca o Não não é isso claro que a
gente precisa ter planejamento
muita responsabilidade é essencial Iel
primordial mas não que isso faça a gente
cair na rotina sabe viver no modo
robótico de ser
eu como exemplo jamais imaginava que
algum dia eu ia tá numa fila esperando
por Um transplante ou que mais tarde eu
ia ter que escolher amputar o meu
próprio pé
é mais uma coisa eu tenho certeza
eu podia aproveitar tudo a minha vida
toda até todos esses momentos e tenho
certeza que eu vou aproveitar tudo o que
ainda há de vir para mim
e por isso eu gostaria nesse momento de
convidar todos vocês para que
transplanta em si o máximo de
positividade de otimismo e se possível
amputee todo e qualquer sentimento de
inferioridade ou mesmo de vitimismo
eu tenho certeza que assim como eu todos
vocês também vão começar a todos os dias
na vida de vocês com o pé direito Muito
obrigado E aí